Speaker 1: To shift gears a little bit before
we get back to covid stuff, as we discussed
many times during the presidency of Donald
Trump, the humiliating and cartoonish nature
of Trump led to many of our historical allies
being distanced from the United States, Canada,
France, Germany, others.
The U.S. was increasingly not a part of major
global discussions on important issues.
Climate, of course, being one of them.
Why on earth would a Trump led United States
be part of climate discussions when Trump
said climate change was a hoax created by
the Chinese allies?
Talk to each other.
But they increasingly did not involve Trump
and the United States and the reputation of
the US was in the toilet, a toilet that Trump
was flushing 10 to 15 times.
Remember that our reputation was in the toilet.
And exactly as predicted, the reputation of
the US is coming back quite quickly.
I got a lot of phone calls during the transition
period from Trump to Biden saying, do you
think we will recover our reputation quickly?
And I said, I think we will, because much
of the world is eager for a non cartoonish
president.
And the US popularity has improved significantly
in several countries since Joe Biden took
office.
This is data from the latest Morning Consult
poll.
Looking at the list of countries, our standing
abroad has increased dramatically in Germany,
where our favorability has almost doubled
from twenty four to forty six percent.
Germany has followed by Japan and France,
where our favorability has gone from 36 to
55 and twenty nine to forty six respectively.
Now to be clear, these are not exactly stellar
numbers.
Despite major improvements, 37 percent of
Germans.
Twenty two percent of Japanese.
Twenty nine percent of French see the US negatively.
Never mind other countries like Canada, 47
percent of Canadians see the United States
negatively.
But the point is, what is happening in the
real world actually does get paid attention
to and it has an impact abroad.
It's not capricious negativity about the United
States.
Trump out and favorability increases significantly.
Now, anecdotally, Americans are also less
stressed day to day because the president,
the former president, was always at risk of
making some horrifying blunder and unleashing
global shame and embarrassment upon us.
We no longer worry about that.
As important as it is to realize that our
reputation does respond very directly to who
is the president and to what the president
is doing, it's also important to realize that
this could happen again.
Most Republicans still like Trump.
Most Republicans still believe Trump won in
November, if you can believe that.
And most Republicans would vote Trump back
today if given the chance, despite the successes
of Joe Biden in his first hundred days, vaccination,
covid stimulus, rehabilitating to some degree
the global reputation of the country.
I'm hearing from friends and relatives in
a variety of countries, including France,
Belgium, Argentina, where I was born in Israel.
It's primarily a feeling of relief that Trump
is gone and relief gets you part of the way,
but it doesn't get you all of the way back
to a recovery in reputation.
Sadly, most of the world understands what
in this country nearly half of Americans don't
understand, which is it's objectively bad
for us and everyone else to elect an incompetent
buffoon like Donald Trump.
It really shouldn't be done again, but it
might be if they get a say and if they're
able to suppress the vote enough in twenty
twenty four.
Remember, they didn't suppress it enough in
twenty twenty they tried, but they failed.
If they succeed at voter suppression to a
greater degree in twenty twenty four, Trump
could be back or someone like him.
Now lastly, just because Joe Biden is restoring
our reputation to some degree.
And doing good things doesn't mean bad things
don't still happen.
They do, and we have to keep paying attention,
which is exactly what we're doing.
In a sense, boring politics is good, but it
can lead to complacency as a result.
And that is exactly how Donald Trump ended
up coming to power.
Now, he has no shot at the Republican primary.
Oh, he won the Republican primary.
Well, there's no way that he can beat Hillary.
I don't even know if I'll vote because it's
just not going to be necessary to defeat Donald
Trump.
Oh, Trump beat Hillary.
Well, then what boring should not mean we
don't pay attention, but it's OK for it to
mean less constant stress about which writes,
is the president trying to take away from
people or media or from whomever?
We are going to continue following the reputation
of the United States around the world, much
improved in many countries, but nowhere near
where we should want to be.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And boy, do we have a good show for you today.
I think we should actually record and keep
today's show, which is not what we always
do, because today's is actually a pretty good
one.